I mean you can't keep a good villain
down so let's do another dipping into
classic Doctor Who and this one is is
kind of a seminal episode in a lot of
ways it's one of the ones that is
generally pretty well regarded it's kind
of a hallmark episode because I pretty
sure was the first and one of them still
now only a handful of episodes of most
in which the doctor is not travelling
with any convenient of any kind I'm
speaking of course of the winner of the
most redundant title award the deadly
assassin starring Tom Baker as the
fourth doctor I'm probably gonna be
getting a little bit more into spoilers
on this one then I might otherwise in
terms of talking about classic episodes
to get into some of the specifics of
with my feelings on it but before I get
into spoilers if you want to know my
general thoughts I like a lot of the
ideas in this episode unfortunately
there are a lot of specifics about the
execution of various elements that don't
work for me some of it is production
some of it is like I like the big ideas
but then the smaller ideas in terms of
how they try and get the big ideas
across don't work for me some of its
performances that there's a lot of
little things that drag down what is in
many ways a really cool idea with a lot
of nifty stuff going on but this is not
one of my I'm gonna be in any rush to to
see again and I have a sort of a small
collection of classic episodes that I
really love and want to have on hand
this would not get added to it so
getting into the specifics so we've got
this story where the doctor goes to
Gallifrey basically after getting a
vision of the president being shot and
getting there and then getting framed
for that and it turns out he is being
framed by the master who hasn't been
seen for a while and is who was on the
verge of dying
who's doing all of this in order to try
and prolong his own life and he's you
know he's doing it to get his hands on
certain artifacts the great key the sash
of Rassilon to try and get to the eye of
harmony and and do what he thinks will
allow him to continue to keep on living
so all of that again conceptually works
and a lot of the visual aspects of
Gallifrey I really like I like the
design of just the interiors of these
buildings it is a cool alien it's a very
70s but it's a cool alien looking kind
of design I like the design on the
outfits you know the big sort of head
pieces and the robes that all looks
really good it looks really cool but in
many ways this story kind of I feel like
I might be able to solidify why I don't
like Gallifrey set stories by and large
and it's because it it's always things
about it that the more we find out about
the Gallifrey ins and the Timelords in
that society and how it works the more
mundane it can all feel and that is
always disappointing to me and I mean
that in terms of nuts and bolts
so like stuff that I'm watching I'm
going really is stuff like Gallifrey has
a news broadcast that's basically like
public television with this doofus
looking up at this horrendous camera
angle reporting on what's going on
really that's how they relay information
to the citizens and it's just such a
it's just such a mundane everyday earth
thing and to have it be the way that
Gallifrey does things you know that sort
of thing is just it always just makes me
feel like I just wish I didn't knew that
I wish I was left for a night oh I
wonder how they communicate
got information whatever was the latest
news about what was going on - its
people and I don't even necessarily want
to know but I want to imagine that it's
something you know really intricate or
just you know this whole other way of
doing these like now they just do just
as a news broadcast okay and that's sort
of my thing like I'm fine with the idea
like I've said before I don't like the
demystifying of Gallifrey and I feel I
need to clarify that because it's not
that I don't want any answers about how
Gallifrey functions it's just that my
experience tells me that the writers and
or the ability of the production
designers either don't have the means or
the creativity or both to realize
something properly alien and instead we
just get very mundane earth feeling
elements and I mean that's and was one
of the things that drove me crazy about
hellbent it's like so Gallifrey is
Little House on the Prairie what you
know it's just it brings it down to this
weird level and it bothers me with
Gallifrey specifically more so than with
any other quote-unquote alien culture
that we ever see in Doctor Who because
by and large usually they might call
them something else but we're dealing
with people were clearly visually human
and you know oftentimes the name that
they give them is just related to
whatever planet they're on so it's not a
huge leap especially considering a lot
of these stories take place in future
settings that we are still dealing with
like some branch of humanity or you know
we're dealing with a mixed culture
there's some aliens there's some humans
and it doesn't bother me in those
situations when I see something that is
more recognizable as that probably has
its roots in earth I can kind of roll
with that but like Gallifrey and the
Time Lords it should be something bigger
bit better than that either that or just
leave it in the dark
that's what I'd prefer and that's not to
say that like I I think
Time Lords on this infallible how dare
you selling the time was like I loved
the fact that their arrogance plays a
really big part of this story the fact
that they just assumed that their
security is fine of course it is why
wouldn't it be
we're Time Lords no one could beat this
security and I love how that arrogance
and that hubris plays into the story in
in many ways the master is counting on
it so I like that it's not like a it's
not like I'm saying you can't Sully the
Timelords it's just don't make them
mundane I mean make them petty in terms
of personality what else if you want but
don't make the that life and the nuts
and bolts and the tactile Nisour that
world into something that ordinary and
there are elements of that here and it's
just something I really really don't
like I mentioned performances and they
are they're a bit of a mixed bag Tom
Baker's great Tom Baker is always great
and so that's not even an issue I
actually also really liked Bruce ax this
is his first appearance I say his first
appearance only time he's played by this
actor but the character crops up a few
more times presumably in other
regenerations you know if that's never
set explicitly but I like him and I like
the dynamic he has with the doctor I
really love that you know he once taught
the doctor and you know the doctor Lee
very good sir can I go now sir you know
like a schoolboy talking to his teacher
and bruises as doctor nine out of ten I
did I like that I like their dynamic I
like to the performance I liked all that
quite a bit
the master Peter Pratt playing the
master I've talked about before when I
did my ranking of the Masters and he did
occupy the bottom spot and it isn't
really Peter Pratt's fault and his
performance isn't bad and I judge that
based off the vocal performance because
you can't see him it's this mask and it
wouldn't be such a problem except it is
supposed to be his face but it's very
clearly a locked-off mask
the eyes are unblinking
yet there's like just this tiny tiny
little movement in the jaw which just
makes it all the more distracting I just
I I don't I don't know how feasible
would have been to shooter in another
way but like in to my way of thinking
they would have been much better off
just really cloaking in heavy shadows
and only showing the face when he's not
talking like he sees him and you know
somebody sees him and then he turns away
and that's when he does his talking like
that would be contrived in a little
cheesy too but unfortunately focusing in
and zooming in on that locked-off mask
that barely moves with these friggin
saucer eyes it really it takes me out of
it it hampers the performance and it it
brings the master down and I'm and
that's unfortunate because like I said
Peter Pratt gives a perfectly
serviceable performance in the part but
that that mask throws things off much in
the same way that Colin Baker's coach
throws things off in six doctor stories
I just I can't look at it and and not
have it distract me so that's a problem
the other performance that is just bad
is Castellon who's kind of the security
kind of guy I don't know who that actor
was but he just he was incredibly
wouldn't he his performance was what I
would expect out of the first ever table
read of the script
he was very wooden he was very closed
off and it sounded like English was the
second language I don't just mean that
cuz he had an accent like he he didn't
seem to know how to do inflection in the
lines to actually deliver anything like
in terms of emotion or naturalism or
anything else and he considering how
prominent he was yeah that was that was
poor poor casting and I you know with
things like that I I don't always know
how much a leeway to give classic
episodes just sort of trying to keep the
limitations in mind and knowing you know
they only probably had on you come this
pool of
there's two pull from the you know these
limited resources in terms of the
visuals and whatever else but at the
same time I look around I see other
solid supporting performance as I
mentioned Barroso even characters who I
don't really light like the little
weasely newscaster guy I don't like that
character but he's still performed
decently for what was written the
castellón just know he's really bad sort
of coming back to one of the things I
said at the front like I said there are
a lot of big ideas that I like but then
there are the little details that end up
not working for me so like the matrix is
it good is one thing so like that's a
good big idea it you know it's the
computer that the doctor can enter his
mind into it is being controlled by the
master or the agents of the master and
it's it's got all these elements sort of
laid in it's kind of illusion but it's
kind of real and and there's like
there's information it there's all stuff
going on here good ideas the actual
visual visualization of that is limited
both by the practical restrictions of
what they could or couldn't afford to do
I do understand that but at the same
time I feel like they copped out a
little bit because like when when the
doctors in there and he's seeing all
these things that don't necessarily go
together like there's just there's an
alligator that snaps at him and there
was a giant spider and there is you know
this this guy wearing a gas mask leading
a horse that's wearing a gas mask and
there's a biplane and and he gets his he
the doctor gets his foot trapped in a
railroad track and almost gets run over
by a train and so much of this is just
it comes back to the same thing it's
just earth stuff and again I do
understand the practical restrictions of
what they had access to they can't build
all this stuff from scratch they don't
have the time or the money but you know
just just one thing to to make
clear that not everything that we're
seeing in the matrix is culled from
earth points of reference cuz again you
know either have it be something
completely bizarre like from Gallifrey
itself or just one alien somewhere to
just make it clear that this is a you
know a mishmash of all these different
elements from all these different things
you know from these different mines and
all this stuff but instead it's just
it's all this birth bound stuff and
especially given that the doctor seems
to be the only time mode that really
cares about the earth all that much it's
just kind of dull and kind of boring
like the moment that kind of perked me
up on the matrix was like I don't know
where he steps in this giant egg and it
kind of cracks and it's gooey and like
that was weird like how the hell was
that there what is it what did he just
step it like in but I needed more
moments like that or even the giant
spider as fake as it looked was at least
something that wasn't just oh that's
like things we have on earth or have had
at some point in history and so again I
like the big idea the matrix but the
details and how they executed that big
idea just kind of kind of took me out of
it again it's not it's not a bad story
and it moves at a good pace being four
episodes long that was a good length for
it again it's a lot of it in the details
and and it's a lot of it is is the
restrictions that Doctor Who is a show
was saddled with but I'm kind of of the
mind if you're restricted so severely in
this way that you can't do this stuff
justice maybe do a different story and
one that you can do justice because
there's something just really
frustrating about a great idea that that
doesn't have the the creativity put into
it that it deserves or that you know
it's there's something about I feel like
there's creativity and the big idea but
when it comes to actually figure out how
to execute it it's written to what
resources do we have on hand and I feel
like that's a--that's a
a sort of mishmash of two approaches
that I just find frustrating I figure
either write a really good story that's
entirely based around the stuff that you
know you have on hand and that you or
that you can make and easily acquire or
do a story with the bigger ideas with
the more outlandish stuff accept the
fact that maybe some of the stuff is
going to look cheap because you can't
afford to build everything from scratch
but at least honor that big idea better
than this kind of does I don't know what
I just said makes any sense at all but
that's that's one of my feelings on the
deadly assassin decent story pretty good
script some good elements but just a lot
of stuff that kept pulling me out of it
and not something I'd be eager to see
again so those are my thoughts on the
deadly assassin the latest episode of
classic Doctor Who that I have worked my
way through have you seen it what did
you think about it whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it all the
stuff that you can follow me on
elsewhere from Twitter to podcast or
whatever descriptions are down below so
check it all out and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]